connor is on the line and he's in Kansas
City hi Conner how are you I'm doing
fantastic Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up well I got some I got
a predicament to put in front and I want
to get your opinion on it I just
recently this past week lost my job
which was on a salary basis and I've got
a part-time job that I still have them
and I'm working at diligently and I've
got about eight thousand dollars in
student loans left as I'm paying those
off continuing to go to school and I've
got I'm helping pay for my sister's
schooling and helping my mother take
care of the house and I wanted to know
what you don't have a job oh I have a I
have I'm very I'm very conservative with
my money I have about 11,000 or 12,000
of it saved and I got a part-time job at
$10 an hour okay well I I guess my point
is is that you you mentioned like five
different things that you're supposed to
be responsible for other people's lives
and your life is not even under control
that was what was scaring me yes so what
happens if your sister and your mother
took care of themselves well they they
uh we we all have taken care of each
other my parents have been divorced for
a long time and since that happened we
all have cared for each other and looked
out for each other and I just didn't
know whether I should pay off my student
loan in one lump sum or if I should pay
you know the minimum the minimum that I
should get each month or what would you
recommend on that how old are you I'm
turning 21 next month and you told me
your student loan balance was what it's
around 8,000 so you could do that you
could do that you'd have 3,000 left in
you a part-time job at 21 years old
what's your game plan then long
or do you want to be when you're 25 and
30 well
I'm I've interviewed for a full a couple
few full time jobs that would require me
to relocate so in the long run I'd like
to just get it paid off in full as soon
as possible so I don't have it looming
over my head where a year from now where
do you see yourself employment was I
hope to be gainfully employed and the
job that the jobs I'm looking at her
around 46 to 50,000 ok very good and
that likely will involve a relocation uh
about an hour or two from where I'm at
now yeah so you would move I'm living at
home currently too I gathered that okay
um let's tap the brakes and put your
Total Money Makeover on hold right now
all right and that would say that you've
got eleven thousand dollars in the bank
you've got an eight thousand dollar
student loan you're not going to do
anything today until you do land this
job and you land this job you're going
to have then and you get settled in the
new jobs you get settled in the new
apartment in the new city you get your
new life organized you're going to use
some of that eleven thousand to make
that happen then when you start getting
your first paychecks if you have enough
left if you have nine thousand dollars
anything above a thousand dollars you've
got at that point throw it at the
student loan if it pays it off
completely that's fine let's restart or
start your Total Money Makeover baby
steps at that point today though I'm
going to call you in the middle of an
emergency a transition and I'm just
going to push pause don't spend any of
the money you're very frugal as it is
and by the way when since you're moving
and taking another job and going to be
in another city it would be good
emotionally for your mom and sister to
have game plans to be caring for
themselves by and large yeah and so that
you're not quote leaving them out in the
cold at the end quote because I don't
want you feeling guilty and then
short-circuiting your career to move
back in with mommy
oh absolutely well and that's what I did
was I left I left my four-year
university to come home and take a job
that I figured I would have forever and
out of out of the corner of my eye
I got blindsided and was let go yeah
okay well yeah you land the next place
and then you go start again and then you
knock out these debts and get yourself
in a strong position and then if you
want to be in a you know from a strong
financial position a good income no debt
a fully funded emergency fund that kind
of thing you'll be in a position then to
actually help others and that would
include your mom and your sister but
today you're not in a position
financially to do that and that's what
was concerning me about the way you're
laying this out so the thing that's the
big next step is land that next job and
make that move and get settled in amen
thanks for the call
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you